the views and opinions expressed on this
program are those of the guests
appearing on the program
and do not necessarily reflect the views
and opinions of eight news now or next
our media group
thank goodness that the governor put the
restrictions in place that he did
tonight on politics now one year after
nevada's first confirmed coronavirus
case
we'll look at what has happened in the
last year and how the valley is moving
forward
a controversial proposal to let a
company create its own government in
northern nevada
we'll tell you about governor siselek's
plan for innovation zones
plus about 70 percent of clark county
clark county's land would be conserved
nevada's largest conservation bill
ever we'll talk about our proposal in
congress to limit development around the
silver state
from eight news now this is politics now
as we acknowledge the scale of this
tragedy that grips our state
i ask nevadans to keep in your hearts
those who have passed away
and the families that have been affected
by this virus
thank you for joining us here on
politics now i'm john langler and we
start with a grim
milestone nevada has now crossed 5 000
deaths from the coronavirus
it's been a year since the first
confirmed case here in nevada
efforts to get everybody vaccinated and
move towards reopening are continuing
the one dose johnson and johnson vaccine
is now in the rotation with the other
two from moderna and pfizer
local doctor michael alswady says there
is no data to show one vaccine works
better for
other groups than certain groups it all
comes down to availability
choice really isn't between the vaccine
the choice is
to get a vaccine if you can get one or
to get the covet infection which you
definitely do not want so all these
vaccines prevent the
severe form of covid which is the one
that you want to prevent
dr allsweed says the johnson and johnson
vaccine might appeal more to people with
busy schedules because it's just one
shot
or those that travel or can't go back
for a second appointment but again
if you can get a vaccine dose you just
kind of got to get it
health officials are putting a full
court press on to help people feel
comfortable taking the vaccine a study
from polling group
civics shows the willingness among black
and hispanic people to get the vaccine
has spiked
since november the black and
african-american population up from 35
to 59 percent as you see on your screen
for hispanic people it went up from 43
to 60 percent
but one group that has not seen a bump
white people it went from 47 percent
wanting the vaccine in november to 48
percent
right now so as we know it's been a long
and abnormal year for all of us
and as we approach a year of pandemic
we're taking a look back
the i-team's david charns went through
some of the major events and is here now
with more david
so john it's definitely been a long year
imagine when this all started we had no
road map
no clear path how to move forward now
five thousand nevadans have died three
hundred thousand have gotten sick
and we're not done certainly putting
this story together was just a reminder
of
how much has happened and how far we've
come
a dangerous virus is spreading rapidly
in china and u.s officials are worried
it will come here
it started as the big unknown an illness
spreading through
china the cdc reporting the first case
of coronavirus in the u.s
the first case would arrive in the u.s
at the end of january
and it would be more than a month until
march 5th
when nevada had its first case this is
the kind of thing that i look at all the
time ryan lavis
is an epidemiologist at unlv and the way
this disease was spreading
it was pretty obvious we were going to
see it in every community in this
country rather quickly
march 5th one case no deaths within a
week governor steve sisilak declares a
state of emergency
mitigate and ultimately contain covid
19.
three days later nevada sees its first
death
and march 18th the statewide shutdown
this is affecting the lives of our
citizens
people are dying businesses including
casinos employing hundreds of thousands
close for at least a month school
shutter
time standing still april 1st
cases 45 deaths in late april
las vegas mayor carolyn goodman suggests
the city become a controller
you're offering the citizens of las
vegas
to be a control group to see if your
theory on social distance now
think of it as an experiment where we're
just offering everyone up as a guinea
pig there's really kind of a wrong way
to have a mindset about this upgrade
may 1st 527 cases
227 deaths in may new cases move
down businesses start to reopen but at a
limited capacity
the strip barren as travelers stay home
june 1st 8 68 cases
445 deaths casinos reopened at limited
capacity
but it's not until the first day of
summer governor sisolak mandates masks
worn in public there was a security
guard who was killed there were people
that were assaulted in stores for trying
to
enforce a mass mandate he thought it
would be unsafe to put that in it would
put the burden
unfairly on businesses and put their
lives at risk by july the white house
coronavirus task force puts clark county
in the red zone
september 1st 69 633 cases
1313 deaths former president donald
trump holds rallies across the state
and tell your governor to open up your
state by the way
this indoor event in henderson violates
the 50-person state capacity limit
october brings a false surge
cases climbing as the weather cools
november 1st
101 479 cases
1781 deaths stay at home 2.0
and the three-week pause we are at a
rapid trajectory
that threatens to overwhelm our health
care system december marks the deadliest
month
kovid now the state's leading cause of
death nevada's surpassing 3
000 lives lost by year's end locally and
regionally many of our funeral homes
are approaching their full capacity
december 31st 227 thousand 46 total
cases
3 125 deaths hospitalization
seemingly on the brink as fremont street
steps back on selling tickets to new
year's eve
but thousands gather on the empty
boulevard we came
just shy of it really breaking the
hospitals but we
finally see the first signs of hope i'm
pretty confident
that we're going to be able to get
people vaccinated over the next several
months that will really make a
big difference two vaccines start
getting into arms and nearly half of
those who lost their jobs are working
again
march 5th 2021 5000 deaths
300 000 cases after a slow rollout due
to lagging supply
hundreds of thousands of nevadans get
vaccinated
it caused a pandemic that was documented
for the first time
minute by minute worldwide a year living
with cobit 19
no one will forget
can't believe it's been a year john and
with vaccinations now ramping
up we are hopefully and i stress that
hopefully turning the corner here
but crazy to think that this is was all
a year ago i mean
we think about it as a year but 365 days
from this week wow it's been a long hard
year for a lot of us david
but thank you for the recap now nevada's
first case was actually a man named
ronald
pipkins joe moeller covered his story
one year ago and spoke with him now
about how far we've all come
when ronald pimpkins came here to the va
copin 19 did not even cross his mind now
one year later
he has a message for others
i think about those days leading up to
actually going to the hospital in
february 2020
ronald pipkins went on a trip with
family to washington
i had no taste
um the actual last night i was
in uh washington seattle i had shivers
and i was cold and i didn't know what
was up
it wasn't until he returned home to las
vegas when things got worse
on march 2nd he went to the va hospital
after being there in less than an hour
they said my oxygen level was very low
he was put in a coma as doctors tried to
figure out what was wrong
that's the last i remember until i woke
up at the end of march
pipkins was diagnosed with copenhagen he
did not get out of the hospital until
april
thank goodness that the governor put the
restrictions in place that he did
because if he wouldn't have
so many people in the state of nevada
would have died last week pipkins
received the copen 19 vaccine my
daughter went through so much
so much pain mentally of seeing her dad
lay in a coma
i i said to myself for my family
i'll i'll do it with three vaccines
available he helps more people
get their shot i wasn't given the
opportunity
to safeguard myself from this virus
but we all have that opportunity now
and so we all come together as a nation
we can get rid of this virus and we can
get on with our lives
pimpkins also thanked the staff and
medical professionals here at the va who
he says
saved his life reporting in north las
vegas joe moller 8 news now
and incidentally pipkins says he's
writing a book about his experience and
his fight with the coronavirus
now to carson city and the legislative
session continues there are several
bills right now
that deal with racially motivated crimes
and what is being referred to as the
central park
karen bill it's assembly bill 157 it
would allow you to sue someone who calls
the police on you just to harass because
of your ethnicity or your sexuality
the measure was introduced by democrat
danielle monroe moreno
its first hearing was this week many
specific occurrences
went viral on social media and incidents
like the bird watcher in central park
asking the woman to put her dog on a
leash
were recorded and gained national
attention during a weekly
news cycle as is often the case
the media exposed exposure led to
more and more of these types of cases
coming to light
the bill allows for a one thousand
dollar damages to be assessed to the
victim
attorney fees and uncapped amount and
compensatory damages
monroe moreno says oregon new york and
washington state have passed similar
bills
another interesting proposition in
carson city it involves innovation zones
governor siselak's proposal to create
self-governing tech communities
now these zones would focus on advanced
technologies like ai
robotics and renewable resource
technology the first of these innovation
zones would be set up
in story county for a company named
blockchains llc
that's a cryptocurrency company trying
to create a semi-autonomous
smart city the proposal would allow them
to set up their own kind of government
within
story county critics compared the idea
to the company towns from the past
economist jeremy aguero says the
proposal is a 75-year project that would
make nevada a tech hub
designed to provide an opportunity
designed to provide an incubator where
this technology can be
tested and deployed and rolled out and
ultimately the goal
uh here being to create something that
can function and continue
now legislation still needs to pass to
support the idea
governor assisilek says the project can
be accomplished without any incentives
or
tax credits so what does story county
think of all this
well this week the water district passed
a motion opposing the idea
well the project would have to import
agricultural water from rural
nevada and they're not too keen on that
still early in the effort though so it's
not clear exactly what role the water
district up in story county would play
it's the largest conservation bill in
nevada history coming up on politics now
we'll look at a bill proposed
to protect millions of acres of nevada
land from development
and keeping yucca mountain off limits
how are dc delegations working with the
white house to stop nuclear waste
shipments to nevada
this is 8 news now welcome back
to politics now back up in carson city a
bill to slow down
and seal eviction records had its first
hearing this week
assembly bill 141 would do two major
things first
landlords would need to give tenants
more notice before an eviction
30 days for a lease less than a year
60 days for a lease up to 3 years and 90
days for a longer lease
republicans claim the law is unfair to
landlords democrat assemblyman howard
watts sponsors the bill
he says too many nevadans are in danger
of being out on the street
as a result of the pandemic nevada is on
the cliff of a major eviction crisis
a gwen center and during the pandemic
found that over
half a million nevadans are a potential
risk of eviction due to the pandemic
the second portion of this bill requires
eviction records get
sealed if the tenant is affected by the
pandemic
the federal eviction moratorium expires
march 31st
in washington d.c nevada's congressional
delegation is continuing its war
on the proposed yucca mountain nuclear
waste repository
a bill sponsored by nevada democratic
congresswoman dina titus would require
the federal government to get consent
before going forward with the
construction of yucca mountain
the proposed nuclear waste dump site is
about 75 miles northeast of las vegas
representative titus says nevada's fight
finally has an
ally in the oval office this would start
the whole process
over a disposal of waste so that
everybody's at the table
and it's based on consent not just ram
down somebody's throat
of course the ally would be president
biden another democrat the rest of the
southern nevada delegation has also
signed on to the informed consent bill
as well
nevada senator catherine cortez masto
has snagged a key
subcommittee assignment she'll chair the
public lands forests and mining
subcommittee
in addition to mining the committee
helps oversee the bureau of land
management
and the blm as you'll know controls
about 80 for 85 percent of the land in
nevada
nevada's congressional delegation also
sponsoring a bill
to set aside 2 million acres of clark
county for conservation
that includes expanding red rock
national conservation area by 51
000 acres 1.3 million acres for the
desert national wildlife refuge
and another 330 thousand acres of
wilderness around the state
the nevada conservation league says it
also encourages affordable housing
if there's a desire to conserve more of
the desert more of the open space around
las vegas
why allow it why are we building out and
not up
seventy percent of clark county uh clark
county's land would be conserved
um that's a huge huge uh chunk of of
area in our county
um and you know there's ways to be to
uh grow again in a smart and sustainable
way
um and this bill uh addresses the
housing crisis that
clark county is experiencing um by
offering the development of affordable
housing for
low-income families and in fact you know
i think that there's
about 70 78 000 um
a shortage of 78 000
homes for low-income families in the
area and this legislation will help
facilitate
responsible growth in the in the valley
and the surrounding areas
and allocates specific land for
affordable housing developments the bill
is called the southern nevada economic
development and conservation act
if you're keeping score at home is more
relief finally in the works
next on politics now we'll look at the
coven relief bill passed by the house
and what might keep it from being passed
in the senate this is 8 news now
you're watching politics now
congress appears ready to pass president
joe biden's emergency covert relief
package but it will be a very close vote
in the senate
our washington d.c bureau correspondent
alexander limon
tells us what to expect moving forward
we're now on track to have enough
vaccine supply
for every adult in america by the end of
may
president joe biden says his
administration has made great strides in
dealing with the coronavirus pandemic
and he wants that progress to continue
this
is a national imperative that we get our
kids back into the classroom
safely and as soon as possible the
president says for schools and
businesses to fully reopen
and life to return to normal congress
needs to pass his 1.9 trillion dollar
american rescue plan
that's why the president worked with
senate democrats on tuesday to ensure
enough support for the package
that would deliver money for vaccines
schools unemployment
stimulus checks and more american people
are overwhelmingly in support
of this legislation a majority of
democrats independents
and in many polls republicans support
this bill
it seems the only group that doesn't
support this bill are senate republicans
and house republicans democratic leader
chuck schumer said the senate will move
forward with the bill as soon as
possible
but republicans criticized the
legislative package saying
it's full of items unrelated to the
pandemic
so we'll be fighting this in every way
that we can
it is my hope that at the end senate
republicans will unanimously oppose it
joining us now to talk about what made
it so hard to get all the senate
democrats on board alex
what's the latest part of president joe
biden's problem was those moderate
democrats in the senate like joe manchin
of west virginia and john tester of
montana for example
and what john tester told reporters is
that they weren't necessarily trying to
get down the amount of money being spent
the size of the package but rather the
issue was that they didn't feel that the
money that was being spent was targeted
enough
so that was part of the issue but it
seems that in the end they were able to
work out a deal
to get all 50 senate democrats on board
something that was
absolutely vital if this package was
going to pass because no republican
senators expressed any support for this
package
changes were made to the package to make
them
happy to go along with it what do they
do to kind of make it work
there were a couple of big changes early
on that 15
an hour federal minimum wage provision
came out not just because
of the objections of these moderate
democrats but also because of a ruling
by the senate parliamentarian saying
that that provision didn't meet the
rules
that that they were operating under to
pass this package
the other big thing that changed was
who's going to qualify for those new
1400 dollar stimulus checks
they decreased how much people have to
earn to be able to qualify so
the stimulus checks start to phase out
now under this new compromise
for any individual making more than 75
000
a year or for couples making 150 000
a year and then they are cut off
completely for any individual making
more than 80
000 and couples making more than 160
thousand and it seems like those two
major changes
were what sealed the deal to get all
democrats to express support and commit
to voting
for the stimulus package that was of
course alexander limon
the senate could vote on the bill as
soon as monday
so how popular are the major pieces of
this bill we're talking about here
as you see on your screen a new monmouth
poll shows extended unemployment
benefits is supported by two-thirds of
the people surveyed
the fifteen dollar minimum wage a little
bit closer that has 53 percent support
45 percent opposed it in this poll
is there life after death next on
politics now one las vegas man paying a
lot of money to try and find out
we'll talk to him next you're watching
politics now
las vegas businessman robert bigelow is
upping his prize
for proof of an afterlife his
organization
bix the bigelow institute for
consciousness
studies offered to pay nearly a million
dollars to the top three essays offering
proof of human consciousness
after death half a million dollars would
go to the best essay
well the response was so overwhelming
bigelow decided to expand the prize
money to 1.5 million dollars
bigelow says applications have arrived
from all over the world
if you're interested in this we have a
story about it george knapp has covered
it for mysterywire.com
and you can find out if you maybe have
something you can contribute to the
effort
that'll do it for us here on politics
now thank you very much for joining us
this week
of course you can stay up to date online
with all the political news here in
nevada
and across the country on
eightnewsnow.com
we'll see you back here next saturday
thank you again for joining us take care
of yourselves
[Music]
you